good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight on Saturday the 21st of
January American Intel Services watched
maybe slack jawed as a white helium
balloon with an enormous payload
swinging beneath it lifted off from
Central China and began to float East
over the North Pacific on the way here
to the United States
within a week it had arrived on January
28th the balloon entered U.S airspace
over Alaska from there it traveled over
the Northwest Territories of Canada and
then it dropped back into the United
States over Idaho
by last Wednesday February 1st it was
spotted by civilians in the Skies over
Southern Montana a man staring out of
the window of an office building in
Billings saw what he thought was a UFO
was too small to be a moon he said and
two began to take pictures which soon
appeared on social media and then almost
immediately the airspace over Billings
over the entire town was shut down
commercial flights were diverted F-22
Raptors arrived from a nearby Air Force
Base along with refueling tankers and an
a-wax surveillance point it was a big
story
so it was at this point when the
existence of an unauthorized Chinese
military aircraft over the continental
United States became impossible to hide
or deny at that point officials around
Joe Biden finally decided to tell him
about it
now we don't know Joe Biden's reaction
to this news but we do know his response
Biden did nothing he did not order the
balloon shot down he did not call for
sanctions or punishment of any kind
against the Chinese government that sent
it
it was not until this weekend when the
aircraft had traversed the entire United
States including at least one classified
nuclear weapons installation that an Air
Force jet finally pierced it with a
Sidewinder missile off the coast of
South Carolina
debris was still fluttering toward the
ocean when the administration began
telling lies many of them about what had
happened
that balloon posed no threat to American
National Security the bite
Administration claimed why because the
balloon never transmitted data back to
China
how could officials know that they never
explained nor did they say with a
Chinese military would send one of its
aircraft all the way to the U.S without
a satellite uplink apparently the
Chinese just forgot they're not very
good at technology
it was a nonsensical claim but as far as
we know not a single reporter in
Washington pressed the administration to
explain that claim and that's not really
surprising reporters in Washington no
longer dig they transcribe
and what they transcribe next is almost
enough to make you cynical about the
role of the press in a free Society
it turns out and we learned this from
unnamed officials on background that
allowing Chinese military aircraft to
surveil your country including your
missile silos is not the big deal the
rest of us thought it was in fact it's
routine it happens all the time Trump
did it too quite a bit of it actually at
least three Chinese spy balloons flew
over this country while Donald Trump was
president and despite the anti-china
rhetoric he just let them pass you
didn't know that now you do so settle
down this is normal
in other words everything Donald Trump
did while President is bad except this
letting Chinese spy balloons fly over
the country that's very good and we're
taking a lesson from him
so virtually every news organization in
this country repeated that claim
including some who should know better
and of course as soon as credulous
reporters wrote their dishonest Stories
the Democratic party and the television
stations it controls repeated those
stories as fact which was the whole
point watch
they are saying we should have shot down
the balloon the minute we saw it
I would use two words
in answering these GOP criticisms they
are premature and they are political
this is why we voted for Joe Biden
because imagine if this had happened
under Donald Trump the way in which the
balloon was taken down allows us to
retrieve the parts of the balloons to
see what was actually in there I'm just
glad that there was no damage or threat
to U.S Aviation operations and that this
operation took place was done in a very
effective excellent way over the
statements from the Republicans
especially in the Senate I've just been
asinine and these jackasses going again
I'll get my shotgun I'm going to shoot
down the balloon
seriously they again they just they make
clowns of themselves
so the balloon shut down the airspace
over Billings Montana including the
airport and as it moved East commercial
pilots
said they were afraid of it they're
afraid of hitting it so it's funny to
see the transportation secretary who's
in charge of all of this tell us who
posed no threat no threat to
transportation
but the best is the dismissal of anyone
who has concerns it's those Republicans
again with their moonshine and their
shotguns and their extra chromosomes
thinking it's okay to shoot down Chinese
spy balloons
when every sophisticated person knows
Donald Trump himself knew the best way
to handle Chinese spy balloons let them
pass again just like Trump did Trump
trump he's good all of a sudden
so the question is did Donald Trump let
Chinese military aircraft float over the
United States unmolested while he was
President well someone asked him he says
he didn't in fact in an interview
yesterday Trump said he had no idea
there were any Chinese spy balloons over
the United States when he was president
and he seemed to mean it
but it wasn't just Trump
's former National Security advisor said
the same thing he said he never heard
anything about Chinese spy balloons over
the country and you would think that he
would have heard
then the general in charge of NORAD
Glenn van hurk had the very same
reaction quote it's my responsibility to
detect threats to North America I will
tell you that we did not detect those
threats
so somehow NORAD the most sophisticated
supposedly monitoring system in the
world missed those Chinese spy balloons
too three of them and by the way so did
the Director of National Intelligence
the man whose job it is to know
America's Secrets he said he never heard
of Chinese spy balloons over the country
during the Trump Administration
here's former dni John Radcliffe
do you remember during the Trump
Administration when uh photographers on
the ground and commercial airline pilots
were talking about uh spy balloon over
the United States that people could look
up and see even with the with the naked
eye and that a media that hated Donald
Trump wasn't reporting I don't remember
that either because it didn't happen
it didn't happen said that a former
Director of National Intelligence you
can see why he thinks that
so again according to Media Accounts at
least one of these three Trump era
Chinese spy balloons floated all the way
to Texas in the center of the country
and yet inside the U.S government at the
very highest levels no one seemed to
know that it happened well how could
that have occurred really
well the bite administration had an
answer
speaking on background to its chills in
the media unnamed officials explained
that these Chinese spy flights were
actually never reported to president
Trump or the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff or even to the Secretary
of Defense why aren't they reported
because they weren't important enough
they were quote relatively minor
territorial incursions
okay so a Chinese military aircraft
hovering over Texas more than a thousand
miles from the Pacific Ocean is a minor
territorial incursion
that's what they said it's pure
absurdity but once again no reporter in
Washington pushed back they just
repeated the lie and then without
warning the White House changed its
talking point undermining the first lie
actually they explained today nobody
knew that Chinese spy balloons were
floating Over America during the Trump
Administration we didn't know
we just found out pretty recently watch
the smarter but more dishonest White
House spokesman spin that Tale
I can tell you that
that we discovered these these flights
after we came into into office I'm not
going to get into the specifics of how
we did the forensics I think you can
understand that we're going to be
careful about that
they're not going to get into the
specifics of the forensics or the
forensics but the one thing they were
really shocked by when they took control
of the US government was how soft on
China Trump was they had no idea he was
letting these Chinese spy flights go
over they were shocked as shocked as
anyone would be that's what they're
saying now of course once again they
can't say more because it's classified
wish we could sorry
so what is the real story here honestly
we don't know the Pentagon ignored our
many questions today of course they did
because we're not going to transcribe
them so once again the people who owe
you the truth are lying to you so all
tonight we know with certainty is that
the Chinese military just flew an
aircraft that reportedly contained
explosives over the entire length of the
United States and got away with it
that seems like a bad precedent
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight